Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two. David P.
Excellent voice mail today about the minimum wage
and its effect on prices. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 6: Hey, David, it's after I was calling to
see if you saw this new article about supposedly
they're raising their average wage to fifteen
dollars an hour. Right. And in order to do so,
they've raised their prices four percent. Mm hmm.
And I thought it was really interesting because
I'm curious, is that four percent the apocalypse
that conservatives have been talking about, if
wages were raised to living wages
like fifteen dollars an hour,
because I can't fathom choosing a four percent
discount if it meant the person that was serving
me was going to pay significantly less.
Speaker 1: Absolutely. So remember when
Obamacare passed, Papa John's went nuts saying if
we have to give our employees health care, we're
going to have to add 10 cents to the cost of every
pizza, to which I said I don't go to Papa John's,
but that sounds great to me. If you came to me
and said, David, would you pay 10 cents more
for your pizza for the knowledge that every
employee has health care? Of course I would.
And you know, a chicken burrito at Chipotle is six
dollars and fifty cents. A four percent increase
would be 26 cents. So now you're saying if
I pay 676 for my burrito instead of 650,
everybody makes fifteen bucks an hour and
everybody now has more money to go out and spend
at other businesses. That sounds fantastic.
There's another example from McDonald's from
a few years ago that the price of a Big Mac would
have to go up by about 10 cents if everybody got
whatever minimum wage raise was being proposed
at the time. That sounds great. And the reason
why it's so small is that labor is only part of
the total cost of a lot of these places. They
have real estate costs, they have insurance, they
have management. They have all this other stuff,
the food costs themselves. You can give everybody
a much better wage and you pay 26 extra cents for
a burrito, which even for people who don't make
that much money, is not a dramatic change to be
able to say, well, everybody now makes 15 bucks
an hour. So I'm not surprised to hear the numbers.
I did see the story, and it should come as
no shock to us that it is not the apocalypse
that the right claims it to be. We have a great
bonus show for you today. We'll talk about Joe
Biden's new plan to donate 500 million Pfizer
vaccines to other countries. We will talk about
a new bit of news involving the Capitol writer
Ashley Babbitt's family. Ashley Babbette died at
the Capitol, writes her family is now suing
for the records on the officer who shot her
and Val Demings. Congresswoman Val Demings
is running against Republican Senator
Marco Rubio in Florida. I love it. More on that on
today's Bonas show. Get instant access by becoming
a member. Right now, there's no reason to wait.
You don't have to wait till next week or next
month. Sign up it. Join Pakman Dotcom, get access
to today's bonus show and I will see you then.